after six months of political
disagreement Iraq's Parliament has
finally passed its budget law
in a session that lasted through the
early hours of Monday morning MPS
allocated 153 billion dollars for this
year and the coming two years
this amount will enable the government
to invest in technology and increase
domestic production especially in the
energy sector but it should also be used
to attract investment to the private
sector that all should be translated
into services to alleviate people's
life's burdens
but this budget depends on global oil
prices remaining at 70 dollars a burial
with Iraq's oil exporting capacity of 3
million and 500 000 barrels a day
many Iraqis are hopeful the budget will
create more jobs maintain services and
rebuild facilities destroyed by years of
war and neglect
but others are critical of certain
aspects of the budget which they see as
a violation of the Region's rights
for people in Central and Southern Iraq
the long-awaited decision is
life-changing
especially with Rising summer heat and
frequent power outages
I want them to reform health care and
education systems our hospitals are a
disaster we need subsidized housing
units because of rent prices are so high
we want the government to take care of
jobless people pensioners and those
under the poverty line as well as our
devastated infrastructure
the bill was approved despite objections
from a number of blocks including some
from the semi-autonomous Kurdish region
in the north who fear this could give
more power to the central government
13 and 14 at the budget law go against
previous agreements between us and the
federal government of Baghdad as they
give back that control over all
production in our semi-autonomous
Kurdish region this is a violation of
the Constitution and we will challenge
it at the Supreme Court
this comes against the backdrop of a
recent arbitration case
which Baghdad won against turkey for
allowing the Kurdish region to export
oil through Turkish territory without
bardad's consent
opposition politicians are warning
unless the bill guarantees a fair
distribution of the budget
it might further deepen disputes between
Baghdad and other regions